thanks for the organizers for putting
together and inviting me David parks I
guess I don't know how exciting this
will be I think a mean presented this
paper in your lab on Friday so so I'm
gonna talk about seating in networks
when the information about the network
is costly and so I think this you
noticed that maybe has some more general
connections to thinking about what kind
of information we should quire how
valuable is that information for making
decisions what guarantees can we offer
when we're not really going to have
complete information of the process that
we're gonna intervene in and so this is
joint work with the same Elenin and I
mean Ryan Lyon so that the general setup
is that we're interested in a problem in
which we're trying to find the best K
nodes in a social network to seed so as
to maximize expected adoptions what do
we mean by seeding here this might be
that we imagine that we somehow have the
power to target them with an
intervention or result in them adopting
our product right and then our product
adoption may spread through the network
as they infect their neighbors with that
behavior right I think you know this is
already a little bit stylized and that
often how we actually can intervene in
networks is not so much by immediately
making people be infected but by
offering them some kind of encouragement
right by offering them some kind of
nudge or inducement to adopt but we're
gonna work with this stylized problem
whereby we can select some seed set of
people who are gonna become infected or
become adopters and then that adoption
will spread through some network and so
this problem is np-hard but maybe if we
assume some things about actually how
this process is going to spread there
could be some nice greedy approximations
and so in particular a lot of what we're
going to look at is under an independent
cascade model this kind of
si r-type model where each infected
neighbor you have has some chance of
infecting you once when they become
infected and it turns out that the that
kind of model of the Cascade results in
a global influence function a function
that maps from the seed set you select
to the total number or set of adopters
that is sub modular and so this is gonna
allow us to if we observe the full
network use a greedy algorithm to get
within this multiplicative factor of the
optimal seed set but generally this
assumes that we know this influence
function we know the processed via which
our product is going to spread in the
network and also that we know the the
whole network because how usually this
is going to work is that we may
repeatedly simulate from the network in
order to compute the what the adopter
set would be from some initial seed set
and we're going to use that too as an
input to our greedy algorithm if we
don't observe the network how would we
evaluate different seed sets and I think
it's really relevant to think about
these cases where we don't really fully
observe the network in particular
there's a lot of interest right now in
interventions in public health develop
and development economics that aim to
spread products in settings where we
have maybe quite limited information
about the network structure and it's
quite costly to collect so for example
Kim at all our did an ambitious field
experiment in which they're trying to
examine methods for spreading the
adoption of multivitamins and a water
purification method in rural Honduras
and so they didn't really have a lot of
prior information about the network
structure of these villages
so they actually mapped to that whole
network structure by surveying everyone
in the village this is quite costly and
in a lot of settings the cost of
measuring the network might really
the cost of the rest of this
intervention right so they measured all
these networks but actually part of what
they did is contemplate avoiding
conducting this costly survey by
considering some seating strategies that
wouldn't require the network so I don't
know why they didn't consider actually
some of the methods it from the
influence maximization literature I know
some of those authors are aware of them
but they were comparing random seating
just uniform random seating in these
villages max in degree seating seating
the people who are named by the most
other people in these networks and then
one strategy that's interesting in that
it uses partial network information what
I call the one hop seating are they
called nomination seating in which you
ask people who are your who your friends
and then you pick one of them at random
so that's a strategy that was proposed
for vaccination and has been employed
also for sensing as well in addition to
seating so the idea is you you know if I
want to select K nodes to seed I'm going
to sample K nodes at random and then
select a random neighbor of each as the
seed right so this only requires that I
talk to K people and it's going to
hopefully exploit a version of the
Friendship paradox whereby your friends
have more friends than you do and so we
will have on average moved to more
central vertices in the network and then
if we think that generally also higher
degree nodes are going to be more
influential than this might be a good
way of seating it might also not be in
fact this this method doesn't really
pool the information we get from talking
to these K different people and it
offers really no guarantees about the
performance of the seats that we select
and in fact it could go very poorly in
some ways if if it turns out that some
of these higher degree nodes are
actually all sort of connected to each
other in the network and so they're very
redundant right and in fact I would say
there's really mixed evidence so far
about the performance of this kind
one hop seating so in some other work
that I won't go into we do some further
empirical evaluation of these kinds of
seating strategies and we're at least
not finding overwhelming evidence in
their favor so one of the things that's
interesting to think about with these
kinds of seating strategies that only
make use of partial network information
is that they're actually stochastic
seating strategies are stochastic
policies that map from the network which
maybe is only partially observed to who
gets assigned to be in the seed set and
so this actually allows you to do a lot
of things like off policy evaluation
with these kinds of seating strategies
so you can utilize data from field
experiments that just do random seating
in order to evaluate these kind of
seating strategies so if you're
interested in that kind of more
empirical taking the problem we have
another paper on that but the you know
the general idea that I think is
inspiring about this sort of one hop
seating is to think maybe there's some
ways of using the network are partially
observing the network that could help us
without incurring the cost of measuring
the entire network I think once you
start thinking about the cost of
measuring the network you may even just
say why do we need to use the network at
all perhaps just randomly seeding or
seeding based on other observable
characteristics right might be
sufficient and so this is the argument
in this recent paper by octopod poor and
colleagues in which they suggest that
you know network information is often
just worth a few seeds more right so the
idea being what if I sort of denominator
cost of measuring the whole network in
terms of my cost of seeding another
person okay how expensive would that
have to be for me still to want to
measure the network and so in their
analysis and they're looking at an
average case over a bunch of family of
random graphs they find that okay
actually just adding a constant number
of additional seeds 2k and seeding those
at random so seeing this slightly larger
seed set that that's going to outperform
optimal
seating of a smaller seed set and so
this this is an argument to suggest
maybe we'd be wasting our time measuring
the network at all unless it's very
cheap to do so right now it's worth
noting that this is an average case
result over a family of random graphs
and also that this is really limited to
cases where things are pretty viral
right where things are actually going to
spread quite a bit and so we're actually
going to result there's going to be a
large number of people who end up a dot
adopting which I mean is every viral
marketers dream but may or may not
reflect reality yeah so with the Cascade
size being just the total number of
adopters at the end yeah so yeah so how
many people end up infected from this
this spreading process okay
so part of what we're gonna do is try to
you know be inspired by both this kind
of warning that maybe network
information isn't always so valuable
also this idea that maybe we can adopt
strategies that are just gonna sample
from the network to do something that
that could offer some of the kind of
guarantees that appear in the influence
maximization literature but with only
this kind of partial information so the
problem as we're gonna formulate it is
that we're gonna work with this
independent cascade model so the idea
here is that each Edge has a one-time
chance to pass adoptions with
probability P right so when vertex
becomes infected then it infects in the
next time step each of its neighbors
would probably bility P and then it's
done it's no longer infectious so if
you're familiar more with the
epidemiological literature this is an SI
R model with deterministic transitions
from I to R so you start out susceptible
you can become infected once you're
infected you only remain infected or
infectious for one period before you
recover or R
moved and so one of the things that's
interesting about this is you can
actually think of this as just a process
whereby we prune the graph we spar safai
the graph keeping each directed version
of an edge with probability P and then
we run a deterministic spreading process
on that graph okay and then we're gonna
try to choose the best K nodes to
maximize the expected number of adopters
and we're going to specify that we
really only have limited access to the
network structure through queries of the
graph so we're gonna think about how we
might actually interact with this
network in order to learn about it
before making this seeding decision yeah
so we're gonna all the results that
we're going to show here are all
worst-case approximation results you can
think about that what happens if you
have some belief network I think things
get a bit easier and we'll mention
briefly some some work in which you
deposit a network model
part of the challenge and a lot of this
right is that many of the models that we
have of social networks don't fit any
social networks particularly well or or
don't necessarily have that much content
so so really relying on the idea that
the actual network is within you know we
can think of it as a draw from some
random graph model might mislead essence
of various ways I mean actually even you
know that book or paper I mentioned
earlier they consider a pretty large
family of random graph models but
there's still some things about that
that set that is a bit restrictive I
think also we really wanted to in this
paper be kind of in conversation with
the influencer maximization literature
which is focus so much on these kinds of
worst-case guarantees and to say that
really we can't do something there I
think in terms of the empirical
important a lot of times you'd want to
try this out upon a lot of realistic
empirical networks and at the end of the
talk I'll show you some simulations of
these methods on an empirical network
okay so yeah if we do if we do think
that our network is drawn from some
particular random graph model that might
help us a lot so there's this there's
this very recent paper by wiggler and
colleagues that looks at what if the
graph we have is drawn from a stochastic
block model in particular a somatic
block model that has this kind of
community structure where there's higher
probability of edges within blocks that
between then one of the ways we could
think about the problem that we have in
doing influence maximization is we want
to make sure that we get seeds in each
of the largest blocks right there's a
bunch of these different communities and
yeah it might be you know possible but
perhaps improbable that the contagion is
going to jump between communities so
it's really important that we seed each
of the largest blocks and so we can do
that by taking a random sample of nodes
using some random walks to try to figure
out are we in large blocks here or in
small
blocks right and then try to seed the
largest blocks
uniformly at random and so then this can
offer some guarantees but these are
guarantees given that we have a network
that's drawn from this particular graph
model so I think this is like an
interesting step inside of the same
direction that we're taking we're gonna
focus on worst-case guarantees right so
what we do here is propose some
polynomial time algorithms that have
these almost height guarantees for
general graphs using a bounded number of
queries and I'll describe to you how we
imagine that we're gonna be able to
query the network and then this gives us
essentially a framework to quantify the
value of network information because by
having this these methods that allow us
to bound the number of queries we can
think about how much do things improve
as we query more right and at what point
do we want to stop querying the network
right so it gives us a framework for
thinking about the value of information
about a network that's not all or
nothing but that instead says look there
might be kind of diminishing returns
to learning more and more about the
network so we have some methods that all
allow us to learn about the network and
then you know to some degree stop and
then see based on that knowledge okay so
the to query frameworks that we're going
to work with we call spread queries and
edge queries and they're both pretty
related and then there we're gonna do
something like run the process of
spreading on the network possibly with
some modifications and so and with the
spread queries we imagine that we can
see a random node and see the set of
eventual adopters from seeing that
random node that is that we're kind of
able to run restricted you know some
kind of restricted version of this exact
spraying process that we'd like to learn
about and so you might think this could
arise it say prior Cascades are observed
right so maybe we have a bunch of
observational data and we think perhaps
this could tell us about the network and
we might also think that in some cases
we can cheaply see the different
behavior so maybe what we're actually
trying to decide to do is you know pick
people to be you know influences who
we're going to compensate in some other
kind of way but we could imagine that
instead we can just do things like these
seeding coupons or links that are low
cost but are spreading via the same
network then in the edge query setup we
think about a case where we can talk to
somebody and observe one of their
neighbors at random and then possibly
repeat this so that we you know talk
with somebody and then we talked with
some of their friends etc right and this
is often used in some prior out of
algorithmic work and I think in terms of
application this starts to look a lot
like various snowball or RDS type
sampling RDS being respondent driven
sampling so I mean it's widely used to
try to measure the size of hard to reach
populations for example like intravenous
drug users so you know I think both of
these query frameworks is we're gonna
present them are a little bit stylized
and so as the person in this team who's
actually the most social scientist
I'm definitely sensitive to the idea
that these are a little bit stylized
query methods but I think they actually
do have an interesting relationship to
how people are really doing these kinds
of surveys so in the edge queries case
we think of it as observing you know a
random neighbor of a vertex and kind of
repeating this you would imagine
actually probably what you do is once
you talk with somebody you might sample
their whole ego net you might ask them
about a whole set of people but usually
we don't ask people for everyone they
know often there's some kind of a cap
they're only going to tell us about 10
people we only ask about 10 people that
kind of thing so it's not it's not so
divorced from the actual kinds of
processes we
used to measure that works here okay so
the thing that's common to these kinds
of approaches is that rather than
optimizing the the influence function on
the original graph we're gonna do so on
a sub graph that's sampled in a
particular way from the original graph
and it turns out that we're going to use
sampling methods that have a kind of
close relationship to the spreading
process itself in order to you know end
up with these kind of properly sample
sub graphs okay so what does the
sampling look like so when we're
considering the spread queries the ideas
that we're going to imagine seeding a
particular vertex and then we're gonna
observe the set of vertices that adopt
given that that vertex is is seated and
so here you know we see the dis vertex
and then the contagion spread from there
and so the idea is actually in the in
spread queries we don't really need to
observe the process via which it spreads
at all so we don't necessarily need to
observe these edges we're only going to
just observe this resulting set of
adopters okay so each query sees a
single node and outputs the identity of
the resultant adopters and then the main
idea is to use the identity of the
doctors from a number of these
independent cascades to then seed k
nodes with optimal approximation
currencies right and so what does this
look like we're gonna repeat this
multiple times so here's one instance of
doing the spread query then we pick
another root node at random and we run
another spreading query the cannot the
root node at random we run another
spreading query right so now we have say
these you know three different spreading
queries that we've run okay so how are
we gonna go about selecting our seed set
the rules of spreading here so the rules
of the sprite aren't gonna be the exact
same as the rules of the spread of what
we're actually trying to spread later so
this is going to be that this is an
independent cascade model where when we
see this vertex here then it spreads to
each of its name
with probability P yeah yeah and we do
consider an extension to another related
contagion model but yeah this is going
to be this kind of simple contagion
epidemiological contagion process right
so we are going to also like the classic
influence maximization work you try to
use a greedy algorithm here and so you
can you know you can think about how
that's gonna apply instead of applying
this greedy algorithm - you know this
full set influence functions estimated
using the full graph up in the Monte
Carlo simulations instead you can think
about what we've just done as having
this very limited number of Monte Carlo
simulations that only involves seeding a
single node and that gives us access to
a bunch of these Cascades so so that is
that the first node that we're gonna
pick in this greedy way is the one that
appears in these Cascades most often
right so the idea is okay you know we
seeded from here and okay did this let's
think about this node it appears in this
cascade in this cascade in this cascade
so if we're in an undirected graph which
is the set up here will consider the
extension to directed graphs in a second
so all the influence is symmetric then
this is also telling us something about
the cascade the probability of a cascade
going from here to this random governor
right so they're thinking about
maximizing is the castex of modular
function yes and then they don't have
any query to the function of access to
unbiased estimators of the gravity which
are all the marginals
yeah yeah yeah yeah we and in the paper
we're definitely drawing on a bunch of
that work on sketching approaches to
optimizing sub modular functions for
sure okay so then so then given that we
have this undirected spreading process
that's going to allow us to find the the
seed that would result in you know these
random nodes adopting most often
okay then how do we greedily select the
next member of the seed set we would
discard all cascades that are already
covered by the seeds that we have
selected and just then look at the the
possible seed that appears in the most
of the remaining cascades here we've
constructed this so that in fact you
know if we have selected the seed first
then all these cascades would be removed
right so we need more of these cascades
in order to really being able to do
anything smart and selecting the next
seed for our scene set right so this is
just a consistent with the idea that in
this kind of independent cascade model
the main thing that you're trying to do
in silicon the set is avoid redundancy
right you're just trying to avoid
sampling seeds that are resulting in in
picking at the same set of adopters as
others can you remind me that's all when
do I okay great okay so one of our first
results here is an approximation
guaranteed for these spreading queries
and so we can then get within this this
found on a loss compared with the
optimal seating and so one of the things
you might be you know disappointed about
here is that we have this loss that's
this epsilon end factor
and so you might wonder you know a lot
of the other kind of approximation
results for these sort of sub modular
functions don't have this kind of factor
right that it's just we have some
constant multiplication factor off of
the optimum but it turns out that it's
impossible to avoid that and so in these
spreading queries it's it's really
impossible to before considering this
worst case scenarios there's paragraphs
where we're going to incur that kind of
a loss so here's here's one of these
four spacecrafts
so you imagine that our graph consists
of a whole bunch of isolates and then
also a clique so we're going to need to
have a lot of these spreading queries
before we hit the clique and so in this
worst case we just miss this clique
entirely yeah to me as someone who cares
about empirical networks it's kind of
encouraging that you know a lot of heart
really worst case results here are
networks that don't look anything like
real networks so that's you know that's
kind of nice but I think we have to you
know consider those kind of scenarios so
so that's that's one of the families of
results is looking at these just running
these spreading processes from seed sets
of size one which could come from
historical data or from that ability to
see things that are bit cheaper than
what we're trying to see do you have any
results for grabs drawn from like a
stochastic
I guess that kind of relates to Ron's
question because these papers you know
get their news see it sets them like
they use spreading queries on seed sets
of size larger than one right right yes
you mean as an input yeah no we don't we
don't have any results on this massive
block models I think we're gonna run
some simulations with that just actually
for comparison with your paper so I
think to me I have trouble getting these
excited about standard versions of the
stochastic block model just this is not
clear that it looks that much like a lot
of the networks were encountering or a
lot of the networks that might be
relatively hard cases here that are like
not like this but that you know are
potentially hard cases as we'll see
actually for some of the other query
methods that we consider this in
different different hard cases but yeah
I mean I guess something like maybe a
degree corrected stochastic block model
gets a little bit closer but also
usually stochastic models don't have
enough triangles in them so I I don't
know it just seems easy to kill this yes
yeah yeah yeah and I think that's one of
the trade-offs in this so this is I
don't I don't you know for those of you
who maybe know some of my other work I
don't normally do like computer science
style like worst case approximation
guarantees so that's just sort of kind
of where we ended up with this is in
some ways really wanted to be in
conversation with the influence
maximization literature and say there's
something you can do here even in the
worst case but yeah I agree
that you know this is not the graph that
we're encountering in reality
so you're hearing it on the previous
slide just trying to interpret what this
kind of bound yeah so up is not order n
interesting yeah so yeah I think that
gets to this point okay if we aren't in
a regime where a lot of people end up
infected maybe this is about that's not
particularly interesting yeah yeah
that's a good point yeah yeah I think
that's accurate so that's I think that's
that is a good point relative to what I
said earlier about this before result
right that's all in this setting where
we have an eventual size of the Cascade
it's order n yeah yeah I think that's I
think that's a good point about this
that maybe in some sense we're in that
we have that same problem is that we're
not really saying much unless things are
ordering yeah okay
so then the other kind of query model
that we consider is this edge query
model where we're gonna query a node and
essentially ask that node to reveal its
edges with probability P independently
at random so this is the same P from the
contagion model and then proceed to
query its neighbors etc so you can see
that this is also kind of a spreading
process in the same way but this will
turn out to be different in a couple of
nice ways so one of the things with the
seeding models we're imagining that we
pay some cost to seed something that's
kind of this cheaper thing to seed right
and then we observe the eventual
adopting set but it's not costing any us
anything as its prey right where's in
this scenario we're imagining we're
gonna have to pay a cost each time we
sort of take a step along the network
because it's not that our coupon is
defusing we're actually going around and
surveying people right and so what we're
going to try to do here also is
and the number of people that we end up
talking to right so rather than thinking
of the queries in terms of seating
you know these cheap coupons we're going
to instead really want to be limiting
how many edges we query and how I would
actually think about this is that
probably what we would do really is talk
with somebody learn a bunch about their
ego nap and then sample some of their
neighbors to talk to randomly so we
being observed a lot more edges because
if I think just as a social scientists
like okay what is the actual set of
costs that you face when you are doing
this kind of surveying it doesn't really
cost that much more to have somebody
reveal ten of their neighbors that did
have them reveal each of their neighbors
with probability P in fact it's not
quite clear how you get them to do that
but without them occurring the cost of
thinking about all their net worth
neighbors so that is that then we're
gonna start from this set random set of
initial seeds we obtain multiple sub
sampled copies of the original graph so
this is gonna look still a lot like the
spreading queries but there's some ways
that this will play out differently when
we get also to directed graphs right so
here's what this edge query might look
like is that we we start from from these
different points and we are taking these
steps again with this probability but we
have multiple starting points here
potentially right so this need not be a
connected component single connected we
repeat this again and we repeat this
again the idea being that we're starting
from these same points but taking these
different random walks so the value of
each connected couple is then the number
of initial nodes that are in this
component so again we're gonna think
about okay if this see sorry in this
potential seed appears in this connected
component how valuable is it to capture
this component well it covers some
random set of starting points and you're
given a game that wearing this
undirected setup these are also any
points these are
till adopters so if if I started with
this in my seed set then this is telling
me something about how likely it is that
these three random vertices are going to
go ahead and adopt eventually okay and
so then we're going to you know employ a
similar kind of greedy approach where
you know the total value of this node is
the sum of the value of its connected
components in each of these Cascades and
so again we were gonna go ahead and
select this greedily select this you
know to be part of our seed set and then
as we repeat we're gonna remove all
connected components that have already
been covered by a previous seat all
right so it's the same kind of approach
okay so then the we also have an
approximation guaranteed here where
we're again going to incur this same
kind of order n loss
one of the things that we get to do here
is that we're going to be able to stop
clearing once a connected component
becomes really large right so in the
seed query we're imagining that we that
the spreading process just keeps
continuing cautiously for us here the
spreading process we're paying each time
that we continue the spreading process
each time we continue this respondent
driven sampling like process and so
we're gonna want to really halt that
process at some point if we're gonna
have any bound on how many people we
query and so once the connected
component gets large enough we can
actually stop query so why again do we
need to have this order end loss here
well there's these cases like this that
are these hard cases here so we imagine
start with a network that consists of a
bunch of K cliques and then you rewire
some subset of the K flex so that
they're connected in a ring to each
other so now they form a giant component
we'd really like to hit this giant
opponent but if we're engaged in this
kind of a squaring process we're not
then we're not really going to discover
these edges we really have to find these
edges in order to be able to distinguish
this connected component from all these
other smaller connected components so
again you know in somewhat encouraging
that we think you know this isn't the
kind of thing that normally happens and
this is a sort of worst case that occurs
when you have P very large when the
contagion is spreading with high
probabilities right because actually I
think in a lot of practical settings the
contagion may not really be spreading
so I think this is on me this is also a
case that's interesting related to the
question about the stochastic block
model because this is actually something
that looks kind of not that different
from a synoptic block model but I mean
part of it is it that we've engineered
this that you're really keeping a
certain number of edges here so it's
much more like a configuration model
version of the stochastic block model
because in a stochastic block model
sometimes these edges weren't it exists
or sometimes there'd be more of them and
so I think that we make this problem
easier yeah okay so I think one of the
big issues in thinking about how to
spread something in our network is a lot
of relationships are asymmetric right so
I have a lot less influence on Oprah
than she has on me and so you know so
it's to me it seems like you really want
to come for this asymmetry in this
process and so how can we actually
account for a handle in case where
there's directed possibly weighted
graphs so everything we do pretty
straightforwardly applies to a weighted
graph now to apply it to a directed
graph gets a little bit more complicated
so and this is actually where I think
the edge queries really shine because
actually if you look at what people do
in a lot of these surveys for public
health or education for development
economics is that they ask people like
who do you go to for advice about X
right so we're trying to say in world
China get people to adopt weather
insurance so we ask people who do you
discuss matters related to farming and
personal you know household finance with
right and then that might be the set of
people who are influencing you right or
who you you know turn to for advice
about health is a similar survey
question used in in some studies and
Uganda so it seems like there were
actually essentially spreading able to
spread in the opposite direction that
the contagion is eventually
to spread it right because if you think
about how all everything that we've
looked at so far works is that we're
using these random starting points and
checking to see whether they would adopt
if we had chosen a particular seed set
right so it's really important that
essentially we're able to read run a
spreading process kind of in the reverse
direction then it's actually going to
run later right but that's precisely
what a lot of these surveys aim to do
they ask people these kinds of questions
and so that's why for example in that
him a tall study in Honduras one of the
strategies that considers looking at
people with high in degree people who
are named by a lot of people because
those are typically people who are
expected to be influential so actually
the edge queries approach essentially
works more or less in the same way right
that we just need to assume that we're
running this process in the reverse
direction so we reveal each incoming
edge with their associated probability
now of course actually this is sort of
reverse the meaning of incoming - don't
want with the contagion as opposed to
the naming process so so that's that's
actually nice it and I think that's one
of the reasons why I you know in
imagining practical applications of this
kind of approach really like our edge
query analysis even if I think it's not
the the number of magic words we have to
make in order to get some of the
approximation guarantees doesn't look as
favorable as the spread queries but I
think it's actually a lot more practical
spread queries that doesn't really work
out I mean basically yes you can imagine
Oh what if we can spread in the opposite
direction
okay there's no way you can really
imagine that you're gonna be able to
cautiously spread in the opposite
direction so if you can't then you end
up with situations like this where we
have a star and you know there's really
no way for us to figure out that this
would be
so we can also send this to some classic
variations on the Keynesian model
including the linear threshold model
I don't really particularly find the
linear threshold model interesting at
all
but results will apply to that okay so
I'll just show you some brief empirical
applications so here we're looking at
one of the largest network in the
so-called Facebook 100 so these early
snapshots of facebook networks at
universities and so there's a lot of
degree variation here and shown on the
right these are the nodes with the large
100 nodes with the largest degree this
is a pretty large network that then
we're going to try running some of these
queries on and see how we do so
essentially we can then look at how many
queries do we run and what is the spread
size that results from it right so if we
run a ton of queries basically we're
just going to recover the standard
greedy optimization approach here if we
were to run no queries or if you don't
really include here we have this random
seeding result then we can consider this
for different numbers of seats so for
this case where we only have two seats
in yellow we see that was actually like
three rapidly diminishing returns we're
able to run a a small number of queries
on this network
you know like under 30 queries and
essentially we have the same performance
we have what we've run hundreds and
hundreds of queries right with a larger
seed set this becomes a little bit
different right you can think about the
logic of our spreading queries that we
ran before we're going to be dropping a
lot of these queries right so in order
to select the second element in the seed
set the second vertex tied to the seed
set we just guard all the queries that
are already covered by our first element
right and so
it there that results in there being
continual games are doing more and more
queries but we see that really you know
we can actually buy you know trading off
between smaller seed set size and a few
more queries we can potentially do
better by using this kind of partial
network information so one way of
thinking about all this practically is
if we specify some ratio of costs for
querying and some costs proceeding what
would be the optimum strategy here so
just as an example let's think that each
unit who adopts we get this revenue 0.01
our cost per query is 0.1 and our cost
per seed is 1 so it costs us 1/10 to 2/3
as the seed so this would be sort of
imagining spreading something that's
much sort of cheaper to see tits it's a
tenth of the cost to seed and I think we
eventually want to see then we see that
there's going to be these kind of
interior Optimum's
where you know it may make sense for us
to go ahead and actually use a smaller
number of seeds so not go for this you
know seed set of size 10 and to collect
some network information but not to
collect an exhaustive amount of network
information so I think what I really
like about this kind of way of thinking
about this is it allows us to consider
you know some interior solution between
collecting the full network information
and just doing random seating right and
I think you know we're continuing to do
a lot of these kinds of simulations with
empirical networks that there'll be kind
of interesting results along these lines
where a lot of times we want to rely on
some network information but not all the
information so in conclusion basically
that is that we're using PACs spread
data or a kind of inner div survey by
RDS or snowball sampling to acquire some
network information then this you know
allows us to think about a way of
quantifying the value
network information that's beyond this
all or nothing and then it counts for
the fact that a lot of times information
about the network is going to have a lot
of diminishing returns so thanks a lot
it was really great working with my
peers on this Amin ride my who's a
postdoc at MIT is on the job market this
year has also been doing some great work
on other work on contagion and networks
as well so thanks a lot yeah your um
your edge query the way you formalize
that it was responding with probability
kind of yeah I guess associated with the
probability do you have any theory the
or yeah do you have any theory to talk
about what if I give you my top sense or
right because that probability is
probably not realistic yeah that's
something we've talked about a little
bit is what if instead we're able to
query your top 10 by probability right
if you imagine there's there's
heterogeneous probabilities of me being
infected by different people and I can
report to you the top 10 yeah I think I
think those various ways that I can end
up being hard to deal with I mean in
practice that's probably a lot of what
this looks like so that's some of the
things that we I would at least hope to
continue to evaluate through empirical
simulations and maybe actually trying
some of these techniques and in field
trials or looking at contrasting actual
adoption data with survey data but yeah
I think it's not something we've tried
to really say anything about formally
so we're PSID for instance you are
worried about getting a representative
sample of households and here it's
almost like bridging the two types right
yeah well what one way of thinking about
I guess we assumed that somehow we can
enter the network at random points
because it really is important in in
these kinds of queries that we've
started from random points right because
that's how we're going to assess how
much of the network we end up covering
right right yeah yeah
yeah maybe someday especially in
referring to the dusting paper the paper
energy yeah so in many social
applications you know more like sure you
know you know things which are not about
your neighbors I can identify who might
be the central in the network right so
the quavery was about note about your
neighbors but about whom do you think is
the most centrally I don't know how much
in there right and then I've got rhythm
but the gallons like in practical terms
it sounds very nice yeah I think so so I
I thought about someone in that paper
what one of things they ask people is
just like oh if I wanted to spread
information about a concert or something
like that in the village who should I
talk to right and so this relies on idea
that not only can I report like local
information of who influences me
directly but who maybe indirectly
influences me so I think that's that's
definitely an interesting angle and in
in some of the other work I've done on
this one hop seeding part of the
question there is like what what
questions you use to elicit the network
how ambitious do you want to be because
I would describe that as a very
ambitious question I'm just like hey
tell me who this seems the seeds that
should be right and maybe people know
that in some cases so yeah I think
that's interesting I imagine we could
formalize that through looking at you
know if we really believe people then
that could be some information about
just the fact that they are included in
the eventual adopter set of that person
yeah that might be actually worth
looking at a little bit more that
requires maybe these strong assumptions
about the idea that people actually can
report who influences them and it's not
so much that I'd be skeptical that I'm
not influenced by these people that I
report but there may be other people who
in fact are more indirectly influential
on me and I don't necessarily
not known to me yeah great thanks a lot
[Applause]